hey everyone a new awesome trailer for
spider-man into the spider-verse drop
this week it's the animated movie
following the Miles Morales spider-man
but it also includes other versions of
spider-man including Peter Parker and
Gwen Stacy so what is the spider verse
and what details did you miss in this
trailer maybe we're gonna break it all
down for you and give our reactions to
this trailer but first welcome to new
rockstars news it's our deep dive into
all the biggest stories this week so
we're also gonna talk about ant-man and
the wasp and this theory going around
that Ultron could still be alive huh and
some new art that's showing the cast of
Avengers 4 and lots of stuff we got a
big episode we're gonna get to all the
stuff that you needed to know from this
past week I'm Erik Bosse joining me at
this table are Sam basher over here
Philip Moline over here hi and now that
that's done with our top story this new
trailer for spider-man into the
spider-verse
it's coming out this December and unlike
the live-action spider-man movies with
Tom Holland as Peter Parker this
animated film stars to make more voicing
Miles Morales the spider-man from The
Ultimate Comics and just explain kind of
what we're seen in this trailer Myles
explains to us that it takes place in a
separate universe from the one we know
the spider-verse refers to a run of
Marvel comics of 2014 that crosses over
all the various incarnations of
spider-man that we've seen throughout
the years so this movie is animated
actually to look like the pages of a
comic book the action is punctuated with
splash pages and action words and you
can actually see some laser print dots
to make it look like it came out of a
CMYK printer it's very cool and yeah
there are multiple spider people in the
Ultimate Comics miles actually takes
over the mantle after Peter Parker dies
but here there's an older but still
broke version of Peter boy by Jake
Johnson and yeah we also see a Gwen
Stacy voiced by Hailee Steinfeld and
this alternate universe is just a little
off from ours if you look closely at the
logos in the background there's all
kinds of fun stuff signs for coca soda
the police car says PD and why instead
of NYPD
red X instead of Fed Ex all kinds of
goofy stuff is you saw something with
like street signs right oh yeah no
actually they're in both trailers you
see the train that I was saying in front
of the the streets that are listed on
like which where this train goes don't
they don't intersect in our you know our
universe but in theirs doesn't matter
before like in the movie but I think if
you throw it in with the rest of this
that's actually pretty interesting they
switch it up that much yeah every flaw
is an easter egg when you're us
virtually an animation you know like the
animators do have to like make a
decision for each of things it's not
like something in the real world or in
the background they designed it all so
it's kind of cool to see that and yes
there are a few villains there's Prowler
he's visible that's actually miles as
uncle in the comics Aaron Davis Donald
Glover actually played a version Baron
Davis and spider-man homecoming do you
know whose voice iam in this movie no I
don't know Hershel alley I'm just really
cool from Luke Cage and what was
moonlight that was yeah amazing
he's great a political show yeah
there's also kingpin he's voiced by Liev
Schreiber there was kind of some hints
toward Fisk in the first trailer and now
it's confirmed
I'm like that's the only thing I'm still
waiting I'm saying exactly what that
depiction is gonna be like cuz kingpin
can be very cartoonish more very like
genuinely threatening and you know like
the Marvel this Netflix show sorry was
my favorite incarnation I've ever seen
of kingpins and I want to see if they
take and learn from that version yeah
that'd be cool and there's also a winged
ultimate version of Green Goblin so not
like the you know glider version of
Green Goblin though in the comics these
like more of a monster and here he has
like wings yeah you still get the cap
you know has like that cap like person
from the 1800s and when you look at that
stupid mirror scene and a few other
Easter eggs if you watched closely you
can see alternate spider-man suits one
it's an electro proof one and the other
is from the secret war comics and the
one in 2004 secret war what do you think
this is taking place yeah that's kind of
is it like a hub like a hub see it seems
like it either belongs to Peter Parker
this area and that would make sense or
it's some other location because Peter
Parker doesn't seem to have his stuff
together well enough to have something
like that begin afford a burger afford
an armory it is kind of a cool idea
though if he's been around for so long
that he had some good strokes of luck
every once in a while and he got a new
suit from a friend or something so
that's pretty interesting yeah and maybe
there's like some kind of organization
with someone overseeing all this and
this is
where they keep it all I mean this could
be owned by like Stark who knows how
rent into the world will go I mean I
guess if it's a Sony property we
probably won't see Tony Stark in it yeah
and then also if you listening closely
at some point Peter in the trailer tells
miles don't do it like me which yeah
it's kind of a quote that Aunt May says
in the Ultimate Comics he says don't she
says don't do what Peter would do do
what Miles Morales would do so it seems
like there's gonna be a lot of nods to
that but um in general what was you guys
take on this trailer D and do you think
into the spider-verse could be the best
spider-man movie when it comes to paying
off specifically what fans love about
the comics it's a big story and it's
interesting that it's into the spite of
her so maybe you're not fully getting in
because the spider-verse event is
enormous but it's cool gwen stacy pops
up in this and that's where she was
created
she's someone pointed out that online
that this might be the fastest like
creation in a comic book to like a film
like transition Bane was like almost
three or four years when you spider
Glenn
in spiders way sorry yeah spider-gwen
but like similar it's it's very quick
this year like pop-up so and it's also
interesting that you're seeing like his
origins and he's being trained and also
you're seeing like prowler show up and
probably a really big deal two miles
origins and you see kingpin it's like
there's a lot going on so I'm just
wondering how they're gonna juggle all
that but if it's into the spider-verse
maybe that's just an intro to like yeah
a bigger threat that could happen over a
couple movie the ultimate TV show
ultimate spider-man I split that
storyline over two seasons knows it so
big so I think that they'll easily this
could be the person at least maybe at
how I'll have a sequel of no trilogy
that'd be I would be super down for that
because I love this animation style and
I like the you mentioned like the laser
dots but I think the other term is
halftone and it's like what you use
sometimes it's like a depth of field or
for shading in comics and so they use
this in this movie to try to add a depth
of feel and still make it feel like a
comic book and it is but you point this
out when you're watching it's like
sometimes you feel like you're something
wrong with your eyes yeah but at the
beginning I was blinking real hard but
there's some it's a really cool use of
at least trying to switch it up and Sony
animation does like to switch it up just
like if we can't be like have the
storytelling up like a Pixar movie or
we're not we don't have like Lego like
maybe we could try different forms of
animation to see if we can like stand
out more and I like that so my favorite
thing about I don't think by the way to
answer your question that it would be
the best incarnation
Spyder I do genuinely believe spider-man
homecoming was the best of what people
like about spider-man and that's the
idea of a teenager is a superhero is
like super-powered and he still is
authentically a teen so he cries he gets
better I love it I still think that's
like gonna be the bar for a long time
but what I do love about this is it
almost plays aside for miles mouths
because that's a great character to just
to go and pay to park covers like it
almost plays the like logical extension
of like okay if a teenager was
authentically a superhero and he's
struggling to like like learn how to
date and learn how to like grow up and
do these things he's gonna be so messed
up that he's gonna be a mess he's an
adult instead of like usually Peter just
gets like like better and more handsome
and then Mary Jane gets like hotter and
hotter and then they just have this
marriage and I'm gonna have their
problems but like he kind of is a like
someone who's never had any problems in
his life and it's like are you kidding
me spider-man is so messed up like how
messed up are we from our kind of normal
childhood
he was spider-man had to keep his secret
from everyone so the fact that he's
totally broken like a slob and stuff I
love that choice oh that might be my
favorite follow-up like to where Peter
Parker ends up yeah the photojournalists
for newspapers don't make a ton of money
especially when they're free leaves you
know they really are we from gig to gig
and living in New York City or even
alternate-universe versions of New York
City isn't cheap so it's but I love that
line of that means money is all tied up
and like something else armories let's
see what he's been the money on yeah I
think it does capture the sense of humor
and the joy in the way that homecoming
did I think this I think Sony's really
playing this card right and it like you
can say that maybe with some of their
superhero properties they're you know
they might be mixing things up a bit too
much but I think when it comes to
spider-man they they were smart to
partner with Marvel when it comes to the
live-action one because they were able
to do so much with the character and
make him as like the best version of him
that he could be but also provide this
this interesting looking animated world
version when just for Miles Morales and
I think for some comic book nerds who
just
love like they are they aren't attached
to logic too much or realism it's more
just this kind of like magic escapism
yeah I think this really captures it in
a way that's visually interesting and is
is not shying away from it or make
confusing you with it they tell you
right away in the trailer it seemed like
there was a message to us is vo it's
like that can't exist in the movie right
yeah he's not gonna be like talking to
someone he's like your universe is like
who's he talking yeah do you have like
awareness like that you don't need to
tell anybody this but uh I did want to
point out one like fun detail but you'll
probably do a breakdown of but I like
the costume he's wearing right here like
with the holes in the mask and also be
kind of weird because in the comics when
Myles gets his powers he's like oh you
should be spider-man and that came that
line comes from Genki who got who got
like kind of ripped off and homecoming
and there is no sign here of what
they're doing with that yeah so it's
confusing but also there's great jokes
about him wearing that right after Peter
dies and he goes up pretending to be
spider-man everyone's like that's really
important it's always a joke it's like
when you shouldn't be wearing that
that's why he gets his own costume so I
think that's I hopefully hopefully that
joke gets translated in a good way in
the movie so yeah it seems like some of
them miles is school background might be
changed a little bit cuz he he goes to
the vision Academy as he does in the
comics and he could see vision on a sign
in the background and in the trailer
shot but he's wearing like a school prep
school uniform where in the comics
that's just where's plain clothes
whatever so it seems like they're making
some changes about exactly what his
school life will be in what kind of
school he's going to and who his friends
might be and maybe they kind of have to
do that because if they were to have
like a separate version of Yankee leave
people to be confused be like wait isn't
that the kid from but yeah I think I
really loved this animation style I
think it's just something like we
haven't seen put like we've seen
different versions of trying to do a
movie that looks like a comic book like
Sin City I think was a really cool like
graphic novel turned into a movie I
think 300 kind of Zack Snyder actually
in its earlier work with with that and
with Watchmen was or Watchmen was really
his earlier work but he seems to have a
good like visual he actually you see the
panel on the screen right yeah yeah he
does a good job translating that and
then
there's some other movies that I think
angley's original Hulk tried to do some
of the split-screen effect books and to
mixed results yeah say you have to do it
in animation style and they do some cool
things by having like the was it was
just a normal spider
it's just puberty or something as he's
passing by like they find a way to like
make these things come to life in a way
that has like a cinematic movement to
now I you are ignoring the original
Batman TV show this also kind of reminds
me of the ultimate spider-man video game
did you ever play that cuz it was done
in the comic book style it was a really
it was where you could play a spider-man
and venom and at the end you could like
to place carnage for a little bit as
well it's a very good game Super
Nintendo game I'd say it's old enough
like all you could do was like swing
down it was a side scroller and you
could just keep swinging oh no this one
was three it was a throw on a different
game but it was done in the same kind of
style not a stylistic but to say it was
meant to feel like it was a comic book
so you got like the bubbles and you got
the sound effects as you would be moving
through the city oh it was really cool
but it was more tied to the ultimate
comics I think well we're very much
looking forward to this movie again it's
coming out in December and right now it
seems like the fall and winter movie
scheduled for the end of 2018 is a
little light other than Aquaman I and I
write the record Ralph 2 is coming out
so this is like another really fun thing
that I'm really looking forward to for
the holiday season but let us know what
you think about this trailer and what
questions you have coming from it
because yeah we look forward to talking
about this more and more as we get
closer to it but for now let's move on
to this week's trivia question
and we got a spider-man themed one here
okay here we go
so in the amazing spider-man the one
that came out in 2012 with Andrew
Garfield Gwen Stacy in Peter Parker eat
a meal it's a specific meal that also
comes up in spider-man homecoming the
one that came out this past summer when
Flash Thompson complained about it not
being fresh what was that meal okay all
of our answers are in the bin now and as
always will later reveal the answer to
the trivia question the close answer is
the side of our judges will do our
sign-off good-byes at the end the video
meanwhile the loser will have to be
funny and it's really hard but fun to
watch right Eric wait look to your left
man she's into you no thanks let's ask
her jokes actually a quick update for
some news that dropped this week
regarding the upcoming ant-man in the
wasp movie hope Van Dyne actor
Evangeline Lilly posted about net
neutrality on Instagram and in doing so
she might have leaked some big don't
wanna know skip to this time but I think
it's something that we all cuz you think
she might be wrong but if she's right it
would be a spoil yeah so it's pretty
funny so Lilly compared the whole
legislative effort that's going through
to houses of Congress to try to get net
neutrality protected she compared it to
two battles that her character had
fought she said quote that was Goliath
now we're facing Thanos so many are
interpreting that to mean that ant-man
and the wasp could be fighting Goliath
as a villain that's a Laurence
Fishburne's character that we've seen in
the trailers and maybe by saying now
this is Stannis it means that hope will
survive to take on Thanos and Avengers 4
which is something that you know we
could have seen coming that dannis would
be the second fight but for Goliath to
be the first fight it's just yeah
considering Goliath is a good guy he's
hit boy in the common becoming
and in the trailer they paint him as a
good guy here's the benefit of the doubt
right maybe she meant one of them's a
good guy just saying right now its
standing at the the house congressman
who are fighting minute reality or I
don't know she I I think that it's very
likely that it's gonna be the kind of
thing where there's maybe some jealousy
a little bit of the plot line from is it
Incredibles has that first one we're
just like a character that's like
adjacent to the action but themselves
like wants to jump in or whatever and so
I think yeah I could totally you could
just so easily see it yeah it's a little
lazy cuz it's done so many times it
wasn't the first Iron Man his friend who
the trailers have had that thing where
there where there's been a clear target
of like oh this is the antagonist here
and it's been ghost right mm-hmm
but it's as far as we've seen a
non-speaking part pretty much right like
it's not a real source of conflict so
then there's got to be someone pulling
the strings
yeah and they haven't shown in the
trailer so then it's probably gonna be
reveal yeah yeah maybe or there's also
Walton Goggins character and he's trying
to get Pym tech as well so possibly he
gets his hands on that Pym tech but
maybe the Goliath assume so it's like
and that was one project they were
working on together at least that would
give Walton Goggins he was like he's a
really good actor it's something like a
little bit more to do and Florence
different could just be a good guy like
they steal the time she could have been
making a biblical allusion right it's
like Thanos when he took on Jesus even
bigger of a threat than Goliath was in
the Bible which I'll say it does seem
like somehow she managed to post an
Instagram picture and the picture is the
moment after she saw what she just did
I feel like went back in time Portugal's
lawyers aren't going to be happy with
that
okay guys an interesting theory about
Ultron has been making the rounds making
us wonder whether the villain
of Avengers age of Ultron could come
back seek revenge in a future Marvel
Cinematic Universe installment well
people are pointing to this shot from
spider-man homecoming when Peter is
locked in the government storage
warehouse remember he tosses aside
Ultron's helmet and clearly at the time
was like a little Easter Egg to the
dozens of Ultron clones that he made of
himself and he passes consciousness
among an age of Ultron but the way
remember we knew which of those robots
Ultron was at any given moment was by
the glowing red eyes and this Ultron
helmet has those glowing red eyes so
could this be Ultron did he survive
visions final strike at the end of that
movie somehow did he was there one other
robot that he like popped back into now
it wouldn't be the craziest thing for
Marvel to bring back an old villain of
course Red Skull just made a surprise
comeback and infinity war after all and
an Ultron that has been locked away in
solitude for years that be way angrier
and badass
basically the tyrant he is in the comics
more so than the Tony Stark invoked one
in age of Ultron the robbery california
version i don't know do you think Ultron
could make his return adventures for to
help in the fight against Thanos are you
guys interested in seeing Ultron again
and if so how should the MCU bring him
back into the near and not as a major
character if they did bring him back in
I think it'd be fun for like in the
background of real small kind of way
which is very silly he's like on a beach
vacation there's something I don't know
he's I don't think it was a successful
enough interpretation of the character
Tobey curious about how would he react
to these events mmm what have you
plugged his head into like a ship and
you had it like there's like a talking
nav like and like I don't know if you
wanna I mean James Spader I have no idea
what his priorities are okay so I don't
know if he wants to do that role but
serious answer to your question I don't
need more
I got enough it was already weird enough
to see those mannerisms come through and
like a metallic body like for him to
design
he designed eyebrows for himself so that
he could emot-- more so people could
understand him anyways I'm fine with
know more but it would be interesting to
see more Vil
like maybe abomination showing up
because if you saw Hulk and abomination
teaming up that would be very scary like
that would be pretty scary to see him
like hop into the fight and then you
just have him snapped out or killed or
something that way you don't have to
worry about him yeah I think you're
touching an interesting thing where I
think both of us are pretty into the
idea that hasn't really happened but in
comic books no one's really dead and it
can be fun too especially the villains
especially successful villains to be
able to bring them back I mean actually
we did just hear about Black Panther 2
without what anything might have
villains returned in that and it's just
like part of that comic nature's of the
fact that like you can't kill evil and
and it'll always find you when you when
you're weak and susceptible to it again
and I think that's fun but then we're
also both like oh all Tron does all OH
hmm he got his own movie it's ok if he
didn't if Klaw showed up I'd be more
actually down for that that'd be kind of
interesting even though he'd be really
not the most helpful person in that
fight I would be more interested in
seeing someone like that not Zemo never
mind I like but there's there's some
other choices and I just don't know if
like the amount of work you'd have to do
to explain why he's still around would
pay off in a really cool way but what do
I know I don't think you would need to
do that much work like they didn't do
they had barely a line for red scold and
people I was like ok no his is almost
the easiest one hopped into a toaster I
don't I don't think we've had enough I
think it was a kind of a missed
opportunity in age of Ultron I think
James Spader did fine I think that movie
you know it wasn't perfect but I really
enjoyed it but I think there's so much
more you can do with this character he
can be so much more maniacal he just
fell victim unfortunately too many of
the Marvel characters and that they
couldn't be the ultimate villain because
Marvel really has been one long 18 movie
movie he leading up to or else being
like think about this so if he was still
alive how scary would it be if you were
able to get a hold of the nanotech that
Tony now has in his armor and if you
wanted to do some Fox Marvel like rumor
mill stuff like we know we saw like I
think you did a video on ER you've
mentioned that Deadpool and cables a
little time Turner thing looks a lot
like the little times you saw in
Avengers 4
and cable dealt with a techno-organic
virus so maybe you could kind of seep
that into the MC it's a very scary
concept of like nanites that are used at
that kind of are can be contracted like
a virus and can alter you into like part
of Ultron or it could just be that
you're being evil robot but basically
you lose a sense of self and that could
be a very cool threat to have in a
future movie if Ultron came back that
would be a very cool way to do instead
of building bodies he literally just
converts people's like I can't blow up
the earth so I could just convert all of
you into me and it's like egos whole
motivation but planet-sized but make a
little bit smaller yeah that could be
something fun that they could do that's
a fun element of Marvel Comics and it's
an important message about chlamydia you
think about this theory do you want it
to be true or you like many people you
had enough you're ready to move on to a
new villain alright another quick news
update from this week everybody we
actually got confirmation that a joker
movie starring suicide squads Jared Leto
is moving forward and we'll follow that
version of Joker and remember it's
separate from this other Joker movie
that's in the works that's the Joker
origins story directed by Todd Phillips
that wolf sounds like will show the
Joker is a failed 80s comedian that's a
separate one this is the Suicide Squad
version of Joker and so it is happening
meanwhile the Harley Quinn movie with
Margot Robbie is also moving forward
she's returning from Suicide Squad so it
sounds like they're each getting their
own movies and her movie will be birds
of prey in which it sounds like the
rumor coming out of this week is that
the villain of that movie will be the
penguin very smart that one's fine very
smart that sides fine birds are Debray
it's fine bursted penguin birds yeah
other thing no thanks yeah yeah who's
like who who wants it anyway Warner
Brothers who wants to make lots and lots
of money and suicides go ahead did that
by accident yeah okay everyone we got
our first look at Avengers 4 perhaps in
the form of some concept art that shows
the surviving heroes from infinity war
now joined by Hawkeye ant-man and
Captain Marvel plan now there was some
confusion over whether this could be
fan-made but several sources are
reporting that this is legit it's it's a
firsthand leak a lot of people are
saying either way let's look closely at
this let's zoom in a minute
we could either zoom or enhance but
let's just look at it so uh cap is
wearing his classic stars and stripes
once again compared to the darker Nomad
esque look that he had an infinity war
and black widows hair is red once more
she was blonde and if anymore that's no
longer the case captain Marvel's suit is
red and blue suggesting that as we
thought she will eventually dawn her
classic colors and not that greenish
suit that we saw her wearing it photos
war machine seems to have a modified
suit and Hulk it's surprising that he
actually is Hulk here he finally came
out to play but yeah he's super his
owner and it's like it kind of looks
like the one Quicksilver was so it also
was leaked the concept art some concept
art of Thanos he's back in his body
armor it's a separate picture and it's
complete Infinity Gauntlet no longer no
longer charred and smoky and he's
carrying some kind of new weapon
interesting but looking back at this
team-up photo once again how do you guys
think an Avengers lineup with rocket and
nebula Captain Marvel Hawkeye and
ant-man added compares to the one that
we saw infinity war with spider-man
vision Winter Soldier Black Panther and
Doctor Strange and Scarlet Witch part of
me thinks this version is actually kind
like I really like this version of the
light what do you guys I mean with Thor
in the background there you kind of
forget but like if you brought Thor to
the foreground it's like this is the
Avengers yeah yeah you know like this
isn't friends the Avengers Plus Captain
Marvel who like if Thor was already as
powerful as they made him in the recent
Avengers movie and she's supposed to be
the most powerful hero we've seen yet
it's kind of like oh I think they're
gonna beat Thanos Superman level yes
they're like threats on your team which
is really cool and I love the hot guy
and I am the hot guy Lily accidentally
tweet something again here's something
though do you guys see what I see next
to Captain Marvel these like tendrils of
smoke
or something they just seem this smoke
monster from Las yes
yeah he can't fight that no take but
this kind of like Titan with some of the
architecture on the side over there so
maybe that could be it but also I'm
gonna be honest I love when Hulk wears
clothes I think that's so I think it's
so funny like one of the better probably
gonna pull for this if Hulk can talk
it'll be like the doc green version of
the Hulk where he has banners
intelligence so they can just you know
he can talk like a normal person but he
usually wears a suit like with a bowtie
and stuff and I'm like that way that's
always great but I'll take the body
armor workout clothes
yeah goes all the way down to his
fingers but you know whatever well I
think the idea there is that he's
wearing that as Bruce and then it's
expand it actually can stretch to an
expanded accommodate whole this with ten
years until we got to there like to get
to the college like this I mean he just
like likes having it all out that's
right yeah he's proud of himself
yes sun's out guns out there's yeah what
I like about this is like I was kind of
sad at the I was very savvy and of
infinity war to see so I'll have these
characters disappear but really I was
sad to see like the funnier ones in my
opinion start to dislike star-lord super
funny Peter Parker and Doctor Strange
bring a lot of like comedic relief to
the movie so I was like oh no this is
gonna be less jokes but man seen like
rocket lineup with them it's like okay
now we're and the new Thor is basically
a stand-up comedian I mean Tony Stark's
always reliable for some some acerbic
wit yeah man he's always a fun one
yeah yeah I think there's a good balance
preserved with like comedic energy but
also like interesting fighting combat
skill that if this is legit and this is
some version of the lineup that we end
up seeing it's like oh I can imagine
Captain Marvel and Thor combining and
some real fun team-up power use in ways
yeah I don't know they need war machine
there
well like somebody go protect the
sanctum sanctorum or something like I do
like his updated costume it looks a
little bit thicker beefier maybe that
means there's a parachute in there
finally who knows yeah why was it there
person why don't they all have
parachutes well let us know you think
about that and what you think about this
art is this the the version that you
want in your head
is there anybody that you want to see
join with them like a Sheree version of
Black Panther maybe or wasp to pop up in
there but ladies and gents it's now time
to move on to our new rock stars news
lightning you guys sweetness questions
I'm gonna fire them at my co-host so to
answer them as quickly and without
hesitation that's possible or you guys
ready all right here we go Phillip at
what if gamer wants to know what else
could these six Infinity stones have
done besides wipe out half the
population saying there's no way these
exist when you put them only together
that they would do one job so what else
could they have done I mean obviously
like there's the alternate plans right
like the more resources make people take
up less resources expand the universe
but mostly I think is probably just sex
stuff so many things and then do it
again brings a smile to his face
it's a matt d girl 1 to 4 wants to know
what are some of your favorite weekend
jams keep it on brain I do sure I guess
the serious answers Odessa and the
Beatles so there you go yeah but only on
the beach Eric this is from at this is
really Sam what's one non nerdy thing
you would love to make videos on I feel
like making videos about anything makes
it a nerdy thing but mmm oh I would say
yeah Sam's weekend James or we had
talked about maybe doing a breakdown of
Childish Gambino's this is America music
video it's it's not really we don't
really do music videos here but man what
a cool music video full of like meaning
and interesting like background
easter-egg stuff if we could do that we
I would love to yeah lightning around
the audience like if you do want us to
do some stuff that you called non nerdy
have failed let us know I'm but we can
maybe break some guys have bad yeah yeah
yeah we we generally only have time for
like that
his stuff and stuff people are like most
obsessed about but yeah we were always
looking for new ideas the biggest cakes
well now comes the time for a 15-second
shout out where each of us is 15 seconds
to shout out plug or ramble about
anything we want Sam why don't you start
I need my space which is from in verse
it's a new podcast that they've done
there's only like maybe eight episodes
there 20 minutes apiece and it's just
nerds who were obsessed with NASA and
the space race and our future as humans
and what we could do and if we have any
questions like there's an interesting
episode they had out recently about
spaghettification and what that actually
means and like when you get sucked into
a black hole if you were to turn around
you could see the entire universe like
even what was behind the black hole in
front of you and you could just see
stars and planets dying in front of you
because you're just being sucked into
nothingness it's really cool yeah
basically basically but it's just as
you're dying yeah it's very interesting
so if you want if you like space I need
my space and go download it for free
great for my shoutout if you live in the
Lausanne in Los Angeles area yeah I some
comedy show shoutouts that I'm doing
this weekend I'm gonna be at the second
City Hollywood location at 7:30 p.m.
Saturday night $5 to get in for that and
then on Sunday night the team that I
coach and direct that I work with named
ad jeans is performing at the Acne
Theatre in Hollywood at 9:00 p.m. on
Sunday night entry fee for that
I think it's $8 at the door five dollars
in advance all proceeds cool and my 15
seconds shout out is go check out the
new trailer for Halloween 9 it is a new
sequel that takes place directly after
the first movie so they got Jamie Lee
Curtis come back they wipe away every
single other sequel they even like make
fun of them and they're like those look
alive like those rely but it actually
looks pretty freaking good so I'm really
excited about a big horror fan check it
out if you like the original Halloween
John Carpenter himself signed off and
said this is the way you should do this
oh wow and blum house was behind it and
they make such good very cool Halloween
h2o is my favorite but I guess that
one's deleted now Busta Rhymes is is
gonna come back for
all right well finally let's return to
the trivia question that we and just to
remind everyone what it was it was what
meal was eaten in in the amazing
spider-man that also came up in
spider-man homecoming as something that
Flash Thompson thought wasn't fresh so
what was I like how I this is like just
one of those things you need to know
like very like that's what the show is
about just what's that stupid thing that
Flash Thompson and one of these re I'm
bitter but I didn't have a good
definition of trivia those trivial of
trivia yeah what what Eric had a pretty
girl in sea baths I know see that's not
good sea bass yeah yeah and then
Phillips said I meet I know good meat I
feel like that might be encompassing
fish meat fish countless meat calm
hashtag fishes me Sam said pad thai I
don't know how all right well the
correct answer was Bronzino branzino
it's the European bass
I remember being some kind of fish right
cuz the family he was poking at the fish
she didn't know how to eat it and then I
guess Tony Rumore Laurie said no and I'm
gonna say if we're gonna go to the
judges I'm just gonna point out that one
of these things that could go bad was
not fresh enough was pad thai if you've
had bad diets essentially noodles but
there's meat and there's shrimp
sometimes I'm pad that's your pet died
encompass the shrimp pet so winner me
lose the best
if you want to put us all through this
we will do okay so as always I will do
our sign off goodbyes first we're gonna
quickly run through some in other news
headlines that we didn't have time for
Philip can read each headline nice well
good any warm-ups today to do these zip
zap zop yeah good good all right here we
go take it away come to me thank you and
the actor who plays Jamie Lannister said
that the scripts for the Game of Thrones
finale episode would digitally
self-destruct after they finished
shooting each scene more like I got hot
here really fast I you know else is
gonna self-destruct my heart after that
finale airs doctors say he's already
made it further than they expected
continue a casting call for the pilot of
the upcoming HBO watchman series called
for a scene to be set in the year 1921
[Music]
paramedics are standing by
watch now I got it it's good scene in
1921 we're gonna have to wear the
provision works we're gonna need to
prohibit me from making more jokes in
future episodes of the show acceptable
joke okay
it's Mel changed in here
bullies star wars fan boys were so mean
to actors Kelly Marie Tran that she had
to take down her social media accounts
y'all suck
no joke but you just all suck by the way
for doing that uh not you all like but
you know not you but but if you're among
the ones that yeah that you know who you
are
you know joke though it's weird it's
like it was like Star Wars was made for
children but you're the ones being the
children just tell me wait at the door
because we have another one he'll live
or die on this one okay that's drying
here walking dead Maggie actress Walking
Dead maggot action also announced she
would be leaving the show next season
along with Andrew Lincoln along with
majority of their audience and finally I
think hopefully there it is alright
stranger things is launching a book
series that will offer advice wisdom and
warnings from the stranger things world
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
playa you got turned upside down I don't
just go ahead and figure that out well
hey let's get a round of applause for
Sam to do it please
all right he's dead r.i.p yeah well hmm
you see that Infinity Gauntlet up there
it's being used for thanks for watching
this week's episode of I'm being used by
the shape of a fist all kinds of things
do use it to do take your complaints to
show it but the Second City huh you have
to pay five dollars for this subscribe
to us for the deep dive bye everyone
I'm sorry we're gonna have to cut so we
all will do with technical difficulties
right well what do you guys think I
think you need to do your apology now I
open up some stomach from uh-oh it's Joe